und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka
guten Abend
kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen fordert von den EU-Ländern
schnelle Waffenlieferungen an die
Ukraine nur so könne sie im Abwehrkampf
gegen Russland bestehen sagte von der
Leyen der Bild am Sonntag das wird aber
nur geschehen wenn die einzelnen
EU-Mitgliedsländer das wollen in
Deutschland ist derzeit noch nicht mal
klar wie schnell die angekündigten
zusätzlichen Finanzmittel an die Ukraine
ausgezahlt werden und ob sie sich davon
auch deutsche Panzer kaufen darf
bemerkenswert dass es seitens der
Bundesregierung immer noch keine
eindeutige Kommunikation dazu gibt
derweil die russischen Truppen in der
Ukraine weiter vernichten und zerstören
einen Überblick zum Kriegsgeschehen von
Christian von Rechenberg
noch hat Putins Offensive im Osten nicht
begonnen den Bewohnern von Hard KEV mag
das gleichgültig sein die Stadt ist auch
ohne Offensive unter dauerndem Beschuss
fünf Tote heute sagt die ukrainische
Seite in mariopoll haben sich die
letzten ukrainischen Kämpfer offenbar
auf dem Gelände des Stahlwerks asafsstal
verschanzt heute hatten sie eine
Entscheidung zu treffen wir fordern die
Ukraine auf die Waffen niederzulegen und
aufzugeben sie retten damit ihr Leben
Kapitulation abgelehnt russlandsreaktion
postwendend man werde nun alle
ukrainischen Kämpfer töten es dürfte
blutig werden für beide Seiten die
Verteidiger an Mann und Material zwar
unterlegen doch das Werk ist riesengroß
unübersichtlich
präsidente Lenski nennt die Lage äußerst
schwierig und warnt
Russland macht einen großen Fehler wenn
Sie all unsere Leute in mariopold töten
und das wird verlieren dann kann das das
Ende jeglicher Form von Verhandlung
bedeuten
Verhandlungen Frieden was für ein Segen
wäre das für all die Menschen in den
Kellern und Bunkern in der Ostukraine in
einem unter der Stadt ist hierodonetz
klebt die 77-Jährige Tamara seit fünf
Wochen
ich vermisse mein Zuhause sagt sie ich
will dahin zurück ich vermisse meine
frühere Arbeit ich will wieder in meinem
Garten sein
Garden wo ist sonnig war und warm hier
unten gibt es kein Tageslicht es ist
kalt feucht zweimal am Tag verteilen Sie
das was andere entbehren konnten
immerhin etwas zu essen etwas zu trinken
los viele wurden krank hier unten sie
husteten hatten andere Symptome und so
weiter und so weiter das Schlimmste war
dass wir keine Medikamente hatten die
Ihnen helfen
woanders wie hier in borodjanka nahe
versuchen Sie weiter das Trümmerfeld in
den Griff zu bekommen eine
sissyphos-arbeit in der schwer
getroffenen Stadt
zum Glück gibt es Freiwillige die sich
um Lebensmittel kümmern sie wollen so
lange bleiben wie sie gebraucht werden
Frau perthivena braucht sie zu Hause
warten zwei hungrige Enkel wo man jetzt
grandios Gott sei Dank müssen wir nicht
hungern für heute reicht's wir hoffen
auf das Beste hoffen das ist das wenige
das bleibt wenn Putins Raketen jederzeit
und überall einschlagen können bei
provarie trafen sie Infrastruktur wie
der Bürgermeister mitteilt Russland
behauptet man habe eine Munitionsfabrik
zerstört
klessenmeister ist für uns in Kiew
Dominik auch in Kiew schauen ja alle
nach Mario Poll mit der bankfrage wie es
dort weitergeht und was dort geschieht
ja fällt Mario Paul dann wäre das ein
Wendepunkt in diesem Krieg denn es ist
ja bisher so dass die Ukraine
mariopold quasi noch als einzige Stadt
im in der Kontrolle hat am sofischen
mehr der Rest ist bereits von Russland
besetzt und
deswegen kämpft die Ukraine auch um
diese Stadt und die Ukraine versucht
natürlich auch die russischen Truppen
dort hinzuhalten weil man hat die Sorge
dass diese Woche diese Offensive im
Osten beginnt und man braucht Zeit man
braucht Zeit die Truppen selbst neu zu
strukturieren um Waffen aus Europa und
den USA auch ins Kampfgebiet zu bringen
und Präsident silenski hat heute noch
mal eindringlich vor allen Dingen auch
an die Europäer appelliert denn schwere
Waffen zu liefern Panzer zu liefern denn
das braucht die Ukraine um in einer
offenen Feldschlacht in der Ostukraine
auch bestehen zu können auch also sich
bewegen zu können gegen eine Docht dann
übermächtige russische Armee und
deswegen blickt natürlich auch Kiew in
diesen Stunden wo auch gerade auch noch
mal Bombardements in mariopol
stattfinden ja sehr auch gebannt auf
diese diese Nacht auch in der Ostukraine
Dankeschön Dominik nach Kiew
dieses Bild aus der Stadt irpin geht
derzeit um die Welt in einem Waldstück
ein Feld mit frischen Gräbern und
Blumenschmuck
eine junge ukrainische Journalistin
twitterte dazu damit müssen wir jetzt
leben kann mir jemand sagen wie
während alle Augen auf die Ukraine
gerichtet sind sollte eine andere
europäische Unruhe Region aber nicht
gänzlich aus dem Blick verloren werden
der Westbalkan russland hat dort eigene
Interessen und sei es das Interesse
Europa zu destabilisieren und Putins
russland hat dort glühende Anhänger umso
mehr muss uns interessieren was es mit
dem Flugabwehrsystem auf sich hat dass
die Chinesen wohl kürzlich an Serbien
lieferten dazu ein Bericht von Wolf
Christian Ullrich
der Flughafen Belgrad bietet
Flugzeugfans normalerweise keine großen
Sensationen aber was Nicola Gajic jetzt
vor die Kamera bekam hat ihn umgehauen
mehrere chinesische militärfrachter das
hatte hier noch nicht gesehen
ist war das Thema historischer Moment
definitiv ein historischer Moment
chinesische Militärflugzeuge in Europa
zu sehen ist wirklich surreal
an Bord der Maschinen so hört man
kostbare Fracht ein chinesisches
Flugabwehrsystem vor drei Jahren
bestellt Serbien modernisiert gerade
seine Armee
die serbische Armee ist heute um ein
Vielfaches stärker als je zuvor und wir
glauben dass unsere Stärke eine gute
Abschreckung ist für alle die unsere
Sicherheit in Frage stellen
die Lieferung passt in ein bekanntes
Muster Serbiens Präsident wucic macht
Politik mit wechselnden Partnern zum
eigenen Nutzen unter patriotischer
Flagge
so lässt er einerseits von Russland
Waffen liefern das ist auch
innenpolitisch populär weil Russland für
viele Serben der große Bruder ist
diskreter kommunizierter gegen das
Serbien am meisten Geld für europäische
Waffen ausgibt unter anderem für
französische ravallkampfjets und auch
mit China macht vucican Geschäfte
militärisch verbindet sie ein
gemeinsamer Kontrahent die NATO 1999 als
die NATO Belgrad bombardierte um
Kriegsverbrecher Milosevic vom Krieg in
Kosovo abzuhalten traf sie versehentlich
auch die chinesische Botschaft Thomas
China und Serbien Teilen eine Geschichte
nämlich fremde Aggression zu widerstehen
wie wir zu sagen pflegen die
Freundschaft zwischen zwei Ländern wird
mit Blut geschmiedet
das China nun jedoch Waffen nach Europa
liefert an das Russland freundliche
Serbien mitten in Putins Krieg für
Peking diplomatisch difiziert
wir hoffen dass die Medien das nicht
überinterpretieren dieses Projekt hat
mit der aktuellen Lage nicht zu tun
niemand bis heute ist Serbien das
einzige Land auf dem Balkan ohne Präsenz
von Nato-Soldaten Vucic Schaukelpolitik
zwischen den Weltmächten stößt jetzt
jedoch an Grenzen
entscheidend Europa sagt du musst auf
der einen oder der anderen Seite stehen
die serbische militärische Neutralität
und der Flirt mit allen Seiten
funktioniert jetzt nicht mehr
alljährliche Paraden täuschen nicht
darüber hinweg Serbiens Waffen sind
veraltet die Nachbarstaaten reagieren
teils besorgt teils gelassen auf die
Modernisierung sie ahnen mehr Schein als
sein
in Wirklichkeit hat die Armee ein
Problem mit dem Personal viele sind
unzufrieden mit dem Gehalt mit ihrem
Status mit der Stimmung in der Armee und
die Leute gehen
die nagelneue Luftabwehr wäre da ein
schönes Bild doch Präsident Vucic Maxi
gerade nicht öffentlich vorstellen er
schaut vermutlich noch von wo der Wind
der Geschichte gerade weht
und jetzt macht erstmal Heinz Wolf
weiter mit den Nachrichten da wird es
zumindest etwas österlich nach
zweijähriger corona-pause konnte Papst
franziskus die Ostermesse wieder auf dem
Petersplatz in Rom mit tausenden
Gläubigen Begehen der Papst forderte in
seiner Osterbotschaft ein Ende des
ukrainekrieges und erinnerte an Krisen
und Konflikte weltweit der Frieden sei
eine Pflicht und Verantwortung aller
traditionell erteilte der Papst zum
Abschluss den Segen urbi@orby der Stadt
und dem Erdkreis
auch in Deutschland haben die Kirchen in
den Osterbotschaften das Leid in der
Ukraine angeprangert der Vorsitzende der
Deutschen Bischofskonferenz betzing
sagte man gebe die Hoffnung nicht auf
dass sich die Welt zum Guten verändern
könne und dass man alles daran setzen
müsse der evangelische Landesbischof in
Bayern Bedford Strom erinnerte an die
verzweifelten Menschen in der Ukraine
und auch an die russischen
Soldatenmütter die umgefallene Söhne
trauerten
nach den Feierlichkeiten zum
Nationalfeiertag hat Nordkorea den Test
zweier Raketen gemeldet wie Staatsmedien
berichten handelt es sich bei den
Lenkraketen um ein neues System für
taktische Atomwaffen nordkorea hat seit
Beginn des Jahres bereits mehrere Tests
unternommen international besteht die
Sorge das Land könne erstmals seit 2017
auch wieder Kernwaffen testen
die Gewerkschaften wollen angesichts der
steigenden Preise in den kommenden
Tarifrunden Lohnerhöhungen durchsetzen
insbesondere gering und
normalverdienende seien belastet sagte
der DGB-Vorsitzende Hoffmann dem
redaktions-
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach erwartet
für September einen corona-impfstoff der
an die omegonvariante angepasst ist das
könnte ich dir Lauterbach in der Bild am
Sonntag an er verwießt gleichzeitig auf
mögliche neue Varianten und
Schutzmaßnahmen im Herbst aktuell sinkt
die sieben Tage Inzidenz sie liegt bei
834,3 weil über die Feiertage weniger
getestet wird könnten die Zahlen laut
RKI jedoch verzerrt sein
Stichwort Feiertage am Ende dieses
sonnigen Ostersonntags dann noch ein
Blick in die Feriengebiete eine
Stadtfeld mit Eindrücken von der Ostsee
mit dem Osterfest beginnt die
Tourismussaison in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern strahlender
Sonnenschein und milde Temperaturen
locken die ersten Urlauber vor allem an
die Küste wie hier in Kühlungsborn in
ihrem Hotel-Restaurant dekoriert
Christine Benz noch schnell die
stellvertretende Direktorin packt
überall mit an im Hotel gilt weiter 3G
im Restaurant nicht mehr das erleichtert
ihr den Saisonauftakt
wir arbeiten weiter nach 3G Verordnung
sind es aber inzwischen auch geübt und
aber für die Gastronomie für die
Restaurants und für alles ist das ganz
wichtig dass da jetzt auch wieder
Lockerungen in Kraft treten
ihr Hotel in erster Reihe am Strand ist
so gut wie ausgebucht insgesamt werden
rund 300.000 Gäste während der
Osterferien im Land erwartet Urlaub hier
wird allerdings teurer bis zu 15 Prozent
gestiegene Kosten für Energie- und
Lebensmittel schlagen durch das macht
auch Christine Benz Sorgen wenn man sich
überlegt dass ein Kilo Roastbeef jetzt
über 10 Euro mehr kostet als noch vor
kurzem
ich denke man sieht es auch überall
gewisse Preissteigerungen lassen sich
nicht vermeiden die Urlauber schreckt
das aber nicht ab
wenn ich das die Leistung haben möchte
die ich die ich hier bekomme dann muss
ich eben auch mit diesen Preisen leben
ja vielleicht mal eine Kugel Eis fehlen
ja als sonst aber ansonsten nee lassen
wir uns davon eigentlich nicht groß sein
drucken ja
neben deutlichen Mehrausgaben kämpfen
die Touristiker außerdem mit
Personalmangel während der Pandemie
haben viele Mitarbeiter den Beruf
gewechselt
55% der Unternehmen sagen uns aktuell
dass ihnen Mitarbeiterinnen Mitarbeiter
fehlen das heißt es ist ein Problem dass
ich durch Corona verstärkt hat und auch
nicht von heute auf morgen zu lösen ist
die Branche rechnet in diesem Jahr mit
etwa 10 Millionen Gästen in MV das käme
den Rekordjahren schon sehr nahe
zum Fußball an diesem Sonntag in der
Bundesliga gab es vier Spiele mit diesen
Ergebnissen Bielefeld Bayern 0:3 Union
Berlin Eintracht Frankfurt 2:0
Hoffenheim Greuther führt 0:0 Leverkusen
Leipzig 0:1
im Frauen DFB-Pokal steht das erste
Endspiel teamfest Wolfsburg hat sich im
Halbfinale 3:1 gegen den FC Bayern
durchgesetzt und trifft im Finale auf
Leverkusen oder Potsdam und jetzt noch
die Wetteraussichten für die kommenden
Tage am Ostermontag ziehen über die
Osthälfte einige Wolken dabei werden 10
bis 16 Grad erreicht in der Westhälfte
scheint meist die Sonne und die
Temperatur steigt auf 16 bis 20 Grad die
nächsten Tage bringen neben Sonne
überall auch Wolkenfelder aber nur am
Dienstag fällt im Südosten etwas Regen
die Nächte bleiben kalt tagsüber werden
neun bis 20 Grad erreicht
das was von uns an diesem Ostersonntag
um 23 Uhr gibt es dann die nächste heute
Express und hier erwarten Sie morgen
Bettina Schausten und Gundula Gause auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]